[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Serien einen schönen guten Abend
den Sport im Blick hat später wieder
Norbert Lehmann schönen guten Abend auch
von mir dann blicken wir gemeinsam auf
unsere Themen
neue Maßnahmen für neue Wohnungen die
Bundesregierung will mehr Familien
fördern und strengere Energiestandards
für Neubauten auf Eis legen
wie umgehend mit der steigenden Zahl
geflüchtete die Forderungen nach
dauerhaften Kontrollen an deutschen
Grenzen werden lauter
und wieder mehr Fußball ARD und ZDF
sichern sich die rechte bis 2028 und
zeigen viele WM und em
Qualifikationsspiele der Frauen und
Männer Nationalmannschaft
[Musik]
in Deutschland fehlen hunderttausende
Wohnungen die Baubranche kommt nicht
hinterher und die Regierung verfehlt
schon wieder ihre Ziele darum lud Olaf
Scholz heute zum wohnungsgipfel ins
Kanzleramt und stellte einen
Maßnahmenpaket vor mit dem man aus der
Krise will das schauen wir uns jetzt
einiges davon an der für Neubauten
eigentlich verpflichtende Baustandard eh
40 kommt erst einmal nicht eher 40 das
heißt das neue Gebäude braucht weniger
Energie höchstens 40% der Energie eines
herkömmlichen Neubaus gelten sollte der
strengere Standard ab über nächste Jahr
jetzt ist der bis auf weiteres
ausgesetzt und beim Bauen oder Wohnraum
kaufen sollen mehr Familien unterstützt
werden die Einkommensgrenze für eine
Förderung steigt von 60 auf 90.000 über
die Entscheidungen in Berlin dort Färber
ein verlassener Rohbau mitten in
Düsseldorf so sieht es gerade an vielen
Orten in Deutschland aus im Kanzleramt
beraten Sie nun wie raus aus der Krise
beim Bauen und Wohnen
ein schlüsselinstrument für mehr
bezahlbare Wohnung ist das serielle Baum
wir wollen also gerne erreichen dass es
möglich ist dass ein einmal genehmigtes
Haus auch anderswo in Deutschland so
gebaut werden kann mit der Konsequenz
dass es eben billiger und schneller geht
ein 14 Punkte Maßnahmenpaket stellt die
Bundesregierung vor unter anderem wird
auf geplante höhere Energiestandards
verzichtet es soll mehr Neubauförderung
für Familien mit geringeren Einkommen
geben und bessere
Abschreibungsmöglichkeiten
mehr Menschen werden sich mit unserer
neuen Förderung ein Haus ein bestehendes
oder ein neues kaufen können und indem
wir den bauen neuer Wohnungen deutlich
leichter machen werden wir mittelfristig
mehr Wohnungen und bezahlbare Mieten
haben ein Schub für die kriselnde
Baubranche soll das sein die aus der
Branche die heute im Kanzleramt dabei
sind zeigen sich erstmal ganz zufrieden
wir gehen davon aus dass er zumindest
den Niedergang aufhalten können wenn wir
wenn es so weiter läuft wie es aktuell
läuft wird das im nächsten Jahr werden
es weit weniger als 200.000 Wohnungen
sein es wird eher Richtung 150.000 gehen
wir gehen davon aus dass über diese
Punkte wir das ganze stoppen können zwei
große Verbände waren heute nicht der
Schienen aus Verärgerung über die
Baupolitik die dauert an
es zeigt sich dass die 14 Punkte die
heute bekannt geworden sind die Lage
insgesamt nicht wesentlich verbessern
werden was wir jetzt sehen ist das
künftige Maßnahmen die bisher nur
geplant werden nicht verschärfend
hinzukommen es tut sich was beim Thema
Bauen und Wohnen umstritten bleibt ob
das reicht
ja dann geben wir die Frage doch gleich
weiter nach Berlin theo ist das was
heute präsentiert wurde ein großer Wurf
wird das die baumisere maßgeblich
entspannt also zumindest haben sich ja
einige wichtige Vertreter der
krisengebeutelten Bauwirtschaft
entspannter gezeigt was dafür spricht
dass das Maßnahmenpaket zumindest als
hilfreich bewertet wird aber da bleibt
noch viel Luft nach oben nicht nur weil
das ganze sehr spät kommt und Teile der
Bauwirtschaft ja schon vor dem
Zusammenbruch der Branche waren sondern
viele der Stellschrauben die verändert
werden sollen die betreffen ja die
Zuständigkeit von Ländern und Kommunen
und die Länder müssten dann künftig
beispielsweise bei der Grunderwerbsteuer
auf viel Geld verzichten was sie bisher
ablehnen aber allen Beteiligten scheinen
zumindest die Dringlichkeit klar zu sein
deutlich erkennbar ist das auch am
Verzicht auf weitere das Bauen teuer
machen der klima-maßnahmen sei es jetzt
die von der EU geplante verpflichtende
Sanierung älterer nicht
energieeffizienter Häuser für die hatte
sich ja Berlin lange stark gemacht oder
den eben erwähnten auch in der Ampel
vereinbarten höheren
energiesparstandard in sogenannten eh40
vor allem für Robert Habeck und die
Grünen war das ein steiniges Stück weg
und offensichtlich ein grüner
krisenpragmatismus der sich zunehmend ja
auch beim Thema Migration andeutet danke
für die Einschätzung nach Berlin Theo
call
ja trotz gewisser annäherungssignale
spaltet aber die Flüchtlingspolitik
weiterhin die politischen Lager mit
Hochdruck wird nach Lösungen gesucht
Länder und Kommunen klagen über eine
akute Überlastung bis Ende August wurden
mehr als
204.000 Erstanträge auf Asyl gestellt
das ist ein Plus von 77% im Vergleich
zum Vorjahreszeitraum immer mehr
geflüchtete erreichen Deutschland über
Tschechien und Polen wie die Lage an der
südbrandenburgischen Grenze zu Polen ist
dazu Nikola Albrecht aus der Nähe von
Cottbus
6 Uhr morgens in Südbrandenburg die
Bundespolizisten haben kaum ihre
Patrouille gestartet schon kommt der
erste Hinweis per Funk
acht Syrer greifen Sie auf die von einem
Schleuser illegal über die Grenze von
Polen nach Deutschland gebracht wurden
aktuell ist die Situation hier in
Südbrandenburg der Alltag Alltag heißt
mehr als 50
illegal eingeschlossene Menschen pro Tag
die meisten aus Syrien das ist die
Bilanz der letzten zwei Wochen
Ausnahmezustand nennt es Brandenburgs
Innenminister Michael stübken und lässt
die mobilen Kontrollen durch rund 1000
landespolizisten verstärken die Zunahme
der illegalen Schleusung gerade über die
deutsche polnische Grenze sprengt gerade
jeden Rahmen wir hatten das in der
Massierung noch niemals gehabt auch
nicht 20 15 16 seine Forderung
stationäre Grenzkontrollen statt mobiler
jetzt muss gehandelt werden ich glaube
es ist notwendig dass der notmechanismus
schenken 24 gezogen werden muss und
unmittelbar unverzüglich diese
Grenzkontrollen eingerichtet werden
Abkommen Stellen stationäre
Grenzkontrollen eine temporäre
Ausnahmeregelung da derzeit an der
österreichische Bayer angrenze in Kraft
für brandenburgsgrenze zu Polen hält die
Polizei Gewerkschaft das allerdings
nicht für realisierbar wir haben weder
das Personal der Bundespolizei noch das
Material um alle 37 Straßenübergänge
nach Polen von Deutschland aus dem
entsprechend auszustatten in Dessau
Brandenburg entschieden die
Erstaufnahmeeinrichtung hier in
Eisenhüttenstadt auszubauen um die
Kommunen zu entlasten 500 weitere Plätze
da sehen sie schon das abgesteckt dort
kommen dann auch Container
in der Bund die Konsequenzen dessen was
er tut selber tragen müsste dann würde
er möglicherweise ein bisschen besser
steuern zurück zu den mobilen Kontrollen
ein Lieferwagen ist den Polizisten
aufgefallen darin eingepfercht 30
Menschen aus Syrien sie werden nun zur
Polizeistation gebracht wofür sie das
langwierige Asylverfahren beginnt
Deutschland darf sich nicht abschotten
zumindest aus Sicht der katholischen
Kirche denn auch angesichts steigender
Flüchtlingszahlen habe sich die
Willkommenskultur nicht erledigt das
erklärte der Vorsitzende der Deutschen
Bischofskonferenz betzing am Rande der
Herbstvollversammlung in Wiesbaden für
Christinnen und Christen sei es Pflicht
Menschen in nottüren und Herzen zu
öffnen so
beim ukrainischen Angriff auf die Krim
vor drei Tagen ist nach Angaben aus Kiew
auch der Kommandeur der russischen
Schwarzmeerflotte getötet worden am
Freitag hatten ukrainische
Spezialeinheiten das
flottenhauptquartier in Sebastopol
beschlossen insgesamt seien dabei 34
russische Offiziere ums Leben gekommen
Moskau Sprachen nach dem Angriff
lediglich von einem vermissten
der Krieg in der Ukraine er belastet
auch das Verhältnis zwischen der EU und
China es sei schwer zu verstehen dass
China sich weigere Russland für seinen
Angriffskrieg zu verurteilen es sagte
eu-handelskommissar Dombrowski ist bei
einem Besuch in Peking und es gibt
weitere Streit Themen Chinas
Subventionen für Elektroautos etwa die
dadurch billiger in der eu-angeboten
werden können oder neue Gesetze die
europäischen Unternehmen den Markt
Zugang in China erschweren dieser Welt
Schäfer dazu
die EU braucht China China braucht die
EU so die offizielle Botschaft in Peking
heute deshalb setze man auch weiter auf
Kooperation heißt das von beiden Seiten
doch in einer Rede vor chinesischen
Studenten am Morgen wird der
eu-handelskommissar deutlicher die EU
lasse nicht alles mit sich machen
die EU begrüßt den Wettbewerb er macht
unsere Unternehmen stärker und
innovativer allerdings muss der
Wettbewerb fair sein und wir werden
selbstbewusster gegen Unfairness
Vorgehen
gemeint ist etwa eine eu-untersuchung
der E-Auto Importe aus China diese
kosten im Schnitt 20% weniger als
vergleichbare europäische Modelle sollte
die
eu-wettbewerbsverzerrung feststellen
durch unerlaubte Subventionen des
chinesischen Staates könnte sie
Strafzölle auf chinesische E-Autos
verhängen
wir haben unsere große Sorge und
Unzufriedenheit über die Untersuchung
zum Ausdruck gebracht wir hoffen dass
die EU Vorsicht walten lässt und ihren
Markt offenhält dies käme den
europäischen Verbrauchern und auch der
globalen Zusammenarbeit beim Klimawandel
zu guter das sehen auch in Europa viele
so die deutsche Autoindustrie etwa
fürchtet chinesische Gegenmaßnahmen aus
meiner Perspektive sind Strafzölle jetzt
nicht der richtige Weg weil eben China
der dritt wichtigste Markt ist für den
Export von PKWs aus Europa wenn wir
jetzt strafzeuge in Europa erheben auf
Elektroautos aus China dann ist das
Risiko da ist es sehr präsent dass eben
eine ja Strahl soll Spirale entsteht und
das wir dann eben ein Handelskrieg
reinkommen das Treffen heute zeigt
einmal mehr für die EU bleibt es eine
schwierige Balance zwischen Kooperation
mit und Unabhängigkeit von China
seit fünf Tagen ruhen die Waffen in
Bergkarabach nach dem Militäreinsatz
Aserbaidschans fliehen jetzt immer mehr
armenische Bewohner aus dem Gebiet in
Bergkarabach das völkerrechtlich zu
Aserbaidschan gehört leben überwiegend
Armenia inzwischen sind über 6.600
Menschen aus der Region in Armenien
eingetroffen das meldet die Regierung in
Eriwan alsoserbaidschan würde das Gebiet
wieder eingliedern und hat zugesagt die
Rechte der etwa 120.000 ethnischen
Armenier dort zu respektieren viele
Bewohner befürchten dennoch unterdrückt
zu werden
zwischen der Karabach und Armenien an
der Grenze ist Nina lieber geil für uns
Nina wie willkommen sind die Menschen
aus bergkambach
einerseits werden die Flüchtlinge aus
bergkara Bach hier in Armenien mit
großer Hilfsbereitschaft empfangen sie
werden hinter mir im Theater versorgt
mit Lebensmitteln mit Wasser mit dem
Nötigsten man muss sich das hier so
vorstellen die Menschen kommen mit fast
nichts manche haben nur Plastiktüten
dabei andere haben ihr Gepäck aufs Dach
geschnallt weil drinnen kein Platz mehr
ist wir haben vorhin erlebt wie hier 11
Personen aus einem PKW ausgestiegen sind
und die Kinder im Kofferraum saßen also
einerseits große Hilfsbereitschaft
andererseits sind viele armenierinnen
und Armenien auch wütend weil es
überhaupt so weit kam weil es überhaupt
dazu kam dass die Menschen so viele
Menschen ihre Heimat verlassen müssen
sie sagen man hätte länger und stärker
um die Region kämpfen müssen jetzt und
da ist er bei janischer Herrschaft
fühlen sich viele bergkamera Bach
armenierinnen und Armenia nicht mehr
sicher das hören wir hier immer wieder
und das zeigt auch diese große
Fluchtbewegung vielen Dank für deine
Schilderung Nina live aus dem
armenischen Grenzgebiet
frankreich will seine Soldaten bis
Jahresende aus Niger Abziehen der
Botschafter soll das Land schon in den
nächsten Stunden verlassen seit Wochen
gibt es massiven Protest vor
Stützpunkten der französischen Armee
nach dem Putsch vor zwei Monaten hatte
sich Frankreich geweigert die neue
Militärregierung anzuerkennen die
Zusammenarbeit bei der Länder etwa im
Kampf gegen den Terrorismus ist seitdem
beendet
ja wir spüren es an allen Ecken und
Enden in unserem Alltag wer einen
Handwerker braucht der muss geduldig
sein der Bäcker schließt früher und die
Kita kann keine Kinder mehr aufnehmen
zur Zeit fehlen in Deutschland etwa
384.000 Kitaplätze der Rechtsanspruch
lässt sich vielerorts gar nicht mehr
einlösen um den Betreuungsbedarf zu
decken müssten knapp 100.000 neue
Fachkräfte kommen auch aus dem Ausland
und wie gut das funktionieren kann zeigt
uns jetzt Markus vollpfiffer
seit fast einem Jahr arbeitet Luisa
Maria gut tierreserango hier in einer
Hanauer Kita während Traumjob hat den
Kolumbien fast alles hinter sich
gelassen Familie Freunde Heimat keine
einfache Entscheidung ich wollte meine
berufliche und personliche Leben
so ähm das war eine große
Herausforderung mit der Sprache mit
pädagogische
andere Kultur kennenlernen Erzieherinnen
wie Luisa sie werden dringend benötigt
allein in Hanau sind 50 Stellen
unbesetzt obwohl die Stadt das Geld und
die Räumlichkeiten dafür hätte wie
andere Kommunen arbeitet Hanau deshalb
mit einer Agentur zusammen einem
Dienstleister der darauf spezialisiert
ist meist junge Menschen für einen Job
in Deutschland zu begeistern wie bei
Luisa in Lateinamerika ist die
Arbeitslosigkeit teils hoch Deutschland
für viele deshalb ein attraktives Ziel
sagen die Vermittler die bürokratischen
Hürden allerdings viel zu hoch
wir haben viel zu lange
Bearbeitungszeiten es gibt zu wenig
Sachbearbeiter die sich um die
Bearbeitung kümmern und es gibt zu hohen
Drang zu übergenauigkeit damit man gar
keinen Fehler macht und das alles führt
zu einer maßlosen Verzögerung der
Prozesse für die Kita in Hanau ist Luisa
ein Glücksfall Kinder und Eltern haben
sich schnell ins Herz geschlossen
sie sucht das Gespräch sie kommt auf
mich zu sie kommt auf meine Tochter zu
und sie hat gar keine scheue Dinge zu
fragen Dinge zu erzählen sie fragt nach
meinem Wochenende wie es leer ging am
Wochenende von Kolumbien nach Hessen
nach fast einem Jahr in Deutschland hat
Luisa ihren Platz gefunden
jetzt zur Fußball nations League der
Frauen Norbert morgen das zweite
Gruppenspiel gegen Island ja und die
erste Begegnung am Freitag das war ja
ein klassischer Fehlstart 0:2 gegen
Dänemark dass DFB-Team wirkt
verunsichert die Devise der
stellvertretenden bundestrainerinnen
Britta Carlsson ein Sieg muss her egal
wie
dieser Blick spricht Bände Ratlosigkeit
überall das
m-frage
ist Tecklenburg hier noch bei der WM
krankgeschrieben Rückkehr ungewiss das
Team braucht Klarheit nach dem 0:2 gegen
Dänemark liegen die Nerven blank und der
Knoten Platz im Moment noch nicht es ist
leider so dass Selbstbewusstsein ist
nicht noch nicht das größte aber auch
dennoch haben wir versucht jetzt die
Mannschaft weiter zu stärken doch eine
Aufarbeitung der WM fand bislang nicht
statt morgen im zweiten Spiel gegen
Island ist der Druck enorm hoch wichtig
ist da halt auch nicht den Glauben zu
verlieren auch wenn es eben schwer fällt
da wichtig ist dass man da zusammen
durch geht und nicht jeder anfängt nur
mit sich selber beschäftigt zu sein die
Olympia Teilnahme ist gefährdet nur die
vier Gruppen ersten erreichten die
Finalrunde der nations League und nur
die beiden Finalisten fahren zur
olympiaqualität nach Paris
ja und das Spiel Deutschland gegen
Island morgen Abend live bei uns im ZDF
zu sehen ab 17 Uhr ja und danach
ebenfalls live DFB-Pokal Preußen Münster
gegen Bayern München
auch in den kommenden Jahren werden ZDF
und ARD von Spielen der deutschen
Fußball a-nationalmannschaften live
berichten sowohl der Frauen als auch der
Männer darauf haben sich die beiden
Sender mit UEFA und DFB geeinigt
die erworbenen TV-Rechte umfassen unter
anderem folgende Wettbewerbe alle
Länderspiele der Frauen bis 2027
darunter die nations League und
Qualifikation sowie Vorbereitungsspiele
zur EURO 25 und WM 27 30 Spiele der
Männer-Nationalmannschaft zu den
Europameisterschaften 24 und 28 und der
WM 26 das ist eine gute Nachricht dass
beides sowohl die Spiele der
Frauen-Nationalmannschaft auch als auch
die der Herren im ZDF zu sehen sein
werden in den nächsten Jahren das ist
deshalb wichtig weil zum einen das im
frei empfangbaren Fernsehen zu sehen
seit wird aber auch wie das mit der
gewohnten hohen sportjournalistischen
Qualität begleiten werden
Hintergrundberichte Erstattung machen
werden aber auch natürlich die
Live-Spiele kommentieren werden ob
analog oder digital alle Plattformen
werden bespielt
[Applaus]
die sechsmalige
rodel-olympiasiegerin natalie
Geisenberger beendet ihre Karriere die
35-Jährige ist die erfolgreichste
deutsche winterolympionikin der
Geschichte und Olympiasieger
alexandersverev steht im Endspiel des
Tennisturniers in shendou der Hamburger
gewann das Halbfinale gegen den
Bulgarien Gregor Dimitrov mit 6237 zu 6
trifft morgen auf den Russen Roman und
kämpft dann um seinen 21 ATP Titel
ja gerade im prima auf das wäre das
vielen Dank Norbert ja das Wetter auch
irgendwie schön und später sommerlich
Details dazu gleich mit den terli
um
21:45 Uhr ist heute journal mit
Christian Sievers wir wünschen noch
einen entspannten Abend Morgen gegen 7
Uhr sind wir dann wieder für Sie da
tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ja in der
Katastrophenregion in Griechenland nach
regnet es schon wieder und hier hat sich
wieder ein Tief festgesetzt das nutzt
wieder die Wärme des Mittelmeers und
dementsprechend gibt es hier wieder
große Regenmengen nicht so viel wie
zuletzt bei der Katastrophe aber 200
Liter auf den Quadratmeter innerhalb der
nächsten Tage sind schon wieder drin
ansonsten herrscht verbreitet hoher
Luftdruck und so steigen die
Temperaturen in den nächsten Tagen
weiter an in der Nacht gibt es erstmal
Nebel nach Norden dann sind die Wolken
mal kompakte Temperaturen gehen aber
schon auf einstellige Werte und ganz im
Westen ist es kalt mit zwei bis drei
Grad Richtung Küsten zwei stellig 11 bis
12 Grad ja und morgen viel Sonnenschein
den ganzen Tag
örtlich muss sich der Nebel noch
auflösen und im Südosten da dauert das
etwas länger und die Temperaturen
steigen bis auf 25 als 27 gerade im
Osten sonst liegen wir knapp da drunter
aber es wird trotzdem ein sehr warmer
Tag die nächsten Tage der Sonnenschein
bleibt uns erhalten nach Nebelauflösung
20 bis 27 Grad am Mittwoch am Freitag
kommen ein paar Schauer auf und damit
ein schöner Abend